Trump has been threatening to do it and
he just made good on his promise I don't
know if you've heard but today President
Trump pulled out of the Iran nuclear
deal yeah yeah out of habit after
pulling out Trump paid around 130
thousand dollars
[Applause]
this never happened people are pointing
out melania trumps in the news these
days people are pointing out that
Melania Trump's new kids initiative be
best sounds a lot like Michelle Obama's
initiative be better yeah yeah not only
of that Melania wants to copy Michelle
Obama's other idea of moving out of the
White House
this is strange president Trump is
urging West Virginians to vote against a
Republican Senate candidate who's a
convicted felon vote against him he's
saying yeah Trump said I don't want that
guy in the Senate I wanted to be my next
lawyer I need it that's Talent
you need talent like that mark
zuckerberg is in the news again Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg is funding a
major effort to find extraterrestrial
life that's true yeah Zuckerberg said I
truly believe somewhere out there is
intelligent life whose personal data I
can sell that's put it together it's
being in rich guys Warren Buffett's in
the news in a new interview billionaire
Warren Buffett called Bitcoin rat poison
yeah which is an unfair comparison
because people actually understand how
rat poison works it makes sense
it kills the rack this is kind of
interesting story I'm from Boston so I
followed the Red Sox it's come out but I
also like other teams it's come out that
Red Sox star Mookie Betts is related to
soon-to-be royal Meghan Markel yes do
you realize what this means
there this means there's a chance there
will one day be a king Mookie your Royal
Highness King Mookie it's gonna take
some doing anyway in Utah I got to
mention this weird story in Utah a
couple gardening in their yard found the
skeleton of a 16 thousand year old horse
yeah after hearing about it Arby's asked
and he meat on those bones we
thank you thank you it took guts to do
that joke and I finally take a stand
against our beast where do I go after
last night Long John yeah yeah I'm a
brave comedian starting at the bottom of
fast food and working yeah
watch out Wendy's
you